هي نسخه الثانيه من مؤتمر بغداد للتعاون
والشركاء مبادره فرنسيه عراقيه عقدت اولى
دوراتها في بغداد قبل اربعه اشهر هذه
المره يستضيفها الاردن بحضور ممثلين عن
ايران وسعوديه وقطر ومصر وتركيا بالاضافه
الى البحرين وسلطنه عمان والمفوضيه
الاوروبيه الهدف تحيد العراق عن الصراعات
الاقليميه وضمان استقرار المنطقه
لا يمكن ان يستمر كساحتي معركه بالوكاله
لقد ضلك ذلك لفتره طويله عليه اليوم ان
يصبح جسرا يساهم في تقليل التوترات
الاقليميه
الخارجيه على هذا المبدا ياكد رئيسا
للفرنسي والمصري ايضا من دون ذكر اسم
ايران
خارج دوني حسن الجوار وعدم التدخل في
الشؤون الداخليه وعدم الاعتداء والاحترام
المتبادل لسياده الدول رئيس الوزراء
العراقيه الجديد والذي يعتبر مقربا من
طهران اكثر من سلفه تحدث عنا علاقات عاذله
مع جميع الشركاء
ببناء علاقاتي تعاون وثيقه ومتوازنه مع كل
الشركاء الاقليميين والدوليين ايران
لتعميقه علاقاتها مع جيرانها خصوصا الدول
الصديقه عند الحدود الجنوبيه للخليج
العربي بحسب كلمات اميره عبد الله